[Music]
mountain bike tires are true
trailblazers specifically designed for
off-road riding wider than regular road
tires mountain bike tires have raised
knobs or lugs that add stability on
uneven terrain built to withstand the
trail these tires can handle it all when
the rubber hits the dirt it's all about
control mountain bike tires are designed
to grip the ground and provide traction
offroad first designers use a computer
model of a tire to simulate the effects
of different rubber compounds
construction begins with rubber
compounds being mixed together to create
parts of the tire ingredients include
synthetic and natural rubbers sulfur and
other chemicals rotating spiral blades
break down the materials friction from
the mixing heats and softens them this
transforms the ingredients into a dough
like rubber compound powerful rollers
squeeze the compound into thick long
sheets and blades cut the world rubber
into narrow strips then the rubber
travels through more rollers that
squeeze it down to the desired thickness
the rubber sheets land on a cart ready
for use
technicians encase steel bead wire with
one of these compounds the bead wire is
the part of the tire that connects to
the wheels rent as steel wire travels
through an aperture the rubber is
extruded to form the casing the machine
delivers the bead wire to a spinning
disc the disc winds the bead wire
shaping it into rings which fit to a
wheel rim to maintain the diameter of
the wire the technician tapes the ends
together holding the shape until the
next stage of production next rubber
sheets with varying characteristics
enter an extruder using heat and
pressure the extruder forces the rubber
through dies this process merges their
characteristics into a single sheet this
sheet will be used to make the bicycles
tread the tread rubber travels through a
channel of cool water meanwhile rollers
coat fabric with rubber to make plies
for the tire casing a moving blade cuts
it into strips this rubber is naturally
tacky so the pieces can be easily
spliced the system feeds the strips to
the tire building machine a skilled
assembler wraps the strips to the
machine drum to form the tire casing and
splices the rubber where the ends meet
[Music]
next robots slide to wire beads around
the casing the ends of the drum fold the
sides of the casing over the bead wires
the technician applies rubber coated
fabric to the bead wires strengthening
the area the Trib rubber is placed in
the center a roller applies pressure as
the drum spins to wind the tread around
the casing then the ends are pressed
together manually and one more turn of
the drum secures the tread rubber to the
casing once vent holes have been cut in
the rubber it's over to an expanding
mold where the tire takes shape the
technician inserts a rubber curing
bladder to maintain the shape of the
tire
[Music]
then he places the mountain bike tires
in curing molds these individual molds
will steam cook the tires under pressure
to further shape them this process forms
knobs and other protrusions on the tire
surface that are designed to grip a
rugged terrain like a big waffle iron
this mold has cooked and formed the
mountain by tire the tire is then placed
on a rack to cold
[Music]
next the bike tire undergoes a
durability test while a computer
measures rolling resistance that's the
energy lost when the tire rotates and an
indication of how easily the tire will
roll this mountain bike tire is now
cleared to travel off the beaten path